holy bunco's kids look out
the keep it moving tour is adding new
dates
we're coming to a city near you come and
see us
some stand-up and we play ayg at the end
of the show
with the crowd we answer your garbage
questions
we've got some trash so far but i know
i know there's deeper garbage out there
around the country
oh yeah so come on out and see us kippy
tell them what they need to know oh baby
we're
all over the place uh providence rhode
island august 11th boston massachusetts
august 12th
new brunswick new jersey august 25th
down tomatoes
timonium maryland magooby's august 26th
couple of crabs and we're going to tejas
baby
uh september 21st we'll be in san
antonio texas september 22nd we'll be in
houston texas
september 23rd through the 25th austin
texas for the moon tower comedy festival
and i ain't done yet august 26 will be
at
four dallas fort worth texas what then
we're bringing it back
to long island baby what in all uh
september 30th
and then we're coming home the boys are
the chickens are coming home to roost
baby
october 27th we're going to be in
philadelphia pennsylvania and then back
down to tejas
uh november 5th through the 7th for
skankfest south get those tickets the
link will be in the description
welcome to another exciting edition of
are you garbage the show where you find
out if your favorite comedians are
classy individuals
or absolute trash now
here are your hosts kevin ryan and
h foley hey
everybody out there and welcome back to
everybody's favorite new podcast
this is r u garbage sure is it's a
little show we sit down with your
favorite comedians and we find that if
they go
to be classy or if they're just a big
old piece of trash sure thing
i'm your host stage foley coming at you
on a beautiful day we're down here in
auntie's basement nice little saturday
she's out with the girls a little
cheesecake factory
yeah yep enjoying herself my co-host is
coming at you from right next to me he
is the
ceo of argue garbage he's really kind of
an international businessman when you
really get down to it
you do have some offshore accounts you
have some i have some interest in
eastern europe i'll be over there
next week checking on your properties
acquiring some more funding this guy's
got a string of laundry mats in
dusseldorf
give it up for kevin james ryan
everybody hey gang happy to be here this
guy's playing slow pitch today
thanks for coming as always please make
sure you review subscribe on itunes full
video available on youtube and then
patreon.com which is [ __ ] cooking by
the way i'm sorry
youtube.com slash are you garbage those
numbers are
true through the roof dude
it's just naturally mature i'm thinking
about i'm just you know it's naturally
i'm just missing it by accident yeah
i'm really pushing that patreon that's
that's where the rubber hits the road
[ __ ] a youtube that's patreon.com folks
check it out for bonus content the whole
nine yards oh fantastic and how about a
nice shout out to our producer
extraordinaire the magic man he makes us
all look good he's out there and queens
doing it keeping it on the streets
t-bone mcmuffin toby and mickey medlen
what's up dudes
hey pal i got a greek super who is
big into conspiracy theories boys
english ain't too great
but he's down to chat yeah he wants to
see what's going on with building seven
gang we could not be more excited to
have our incredibly special guest
back with us again today he's back on
the show for the second time
uh got a little company in the building
he was an early adopter
early early early guest one of the uh
one of the founding fathers i don't i
don't hate that
i don't hate that all right good friend
of ours very funny stand-up comedian
uh you know him as one half of the
amazing irish goodbye podcast
and one-third of here's the scenario
which you gotta check out give it up for
our good pal
mike feeney everybody hey hi everyone
happy to be back i'm happy to be still
doing the stash too i like you oh yeah
yeah and
by the way can i just say very very
happy for you guys
thank you i did it we did it like i said
we were saying joking around earlier we
did it very early
in the uh over zoom and now you guys got
a whole
there's a whole studio here you guys got
i mean just a hell of a producer who's
already on his phone i mean you guys
you got so much stuff going on here
check in we got company over here
oh my bad i was looking up a
hypothetical question sent from a
listener from the uk to help plug your
show
my bad dude toby's hot today yeah
[Laughter]
go kick the hacky sack around
you guys got the rogan shout out i mean
you guys are getting bigger and bigger
and the podcast also seems like it's
doing well
fat jokes but last time i was here you
guys said that i was uh
i was majority garbage yeah you said 80
you said something in the 70s or
something but i'm i'm here to
i'm here to make that number even lower
because i think i
think you leveled up i'm sorry i was
going to say that
this is the most trashy i've ever seen
no bro this is this is me going into my
final form
that shows how trashy you really are
right you think this is classed up
this is i mean listen do me a favor
uh-huh open your shirt a little bit i
want to see what you have underneath
there
that's a great wife beater with a three
dollar necklace
baby so what were you saying i'm the
everyman
holy hell a gray life beater is a tattoo
what am i supposed to wear black white
or white no not white you can't wear a
white wife beater
ever under any circumstances and black
is just too it
especially on a white shirt it po it
bleeds through you got to get gray
that grey's a tough look yeah if you
opened that shirt and laid down
and people walked by oh this guy od yeah
yeah 100 sorry i can't just wear a black
boring shirt i mean the only difference
between you two is you have a v just to
get it over your head
that started with off
that came as a crew i mean come on this
is a great only guy with a d-neck
it's banana republic baby now what is
garbage this is
i believe you that's pretty good it's
pretty nice i believe it's pretty nice
yeah but definitely not going in the in
the in the
direction of class let me tell you
because plus leg tattoos
i checked out like tattoos are great
they don't you have a mets tattoo no
you said that last time and it offended
me last time you got a very messy vibe
the last time i was here i i did the
show i was i was in a bad place you know
i had i had a couch that was a motorized
raymore and flanagan couch that was half
broken and stuff
that's been replaced by west elm oh
really west elm that's pretty nice new
west elmer did you get it like on no i
got a marketplace i got a new i i paid
i paid i dropped the number what's the
number on the website
four digies four digi four
thousand yeah at least pretty good yeah
yeah because you pay for it all at once
well that's not that much they don't
know how to hold them they don't offer a
payment plan
over at the west elm pam shout out to
wayfair
you got just what i need shout out to
klorna 79 payments of 14.99
wayfair is more of a friend yeah you
borrow [ __ ]
yeah yeah yeah lay away give me a cup of
sugar
yeah they really are one step above
rent-a-center
i've never gotten a good piece of
furniture from wayfair yeah that lasts
you can't remember you sleep on that
couch one time and it's [ __ ]
flattened
remember that whole conspiracy theory
how they're doing like child
yeah in the closets it would be like you
could order
people you can order like a brittany for
16 thousand dollars and you're like this
is just
just says like balsa wood you're like
yeah
that was one of those conspiracy
theories i didn't really get in maybe
toby's landlord
yeah tell me what's your greek landlord
i'd have to say about it buddy buddy
renaissance is no good
don't trust the wayfarer right now huh
um he told me if you're going to smoke
you have to smoke good cigarettes i was
like all right dude
what is a good cigarette to him weed to
hit me paul mall
man that's no good that's no good
palmost um
what other i i'm curious as to what
other all right so you got the couch the
couch is upgraded what other upgrades
you feel over the past year it's
probably been about a year since you've
been on
more than a year more than a year what
do you think what other things have you
been like oh i feel good about this part
i feel good about
kind of getting this together a little
bit um
and is the mustache one of them the
mustache just started as a joke and now
it's become an identity
and i it's actually taken over me like
venom i i can't i'm calling
i can't get rid of it i'm calling people
buttercup now i don't know what's going
on we actually both we actually booked a
mustache
just came with it we were talking the
other day
we got to get that mustache in here he's
doing numbers yeah oh
oh here's another big one this is the i
uh i got a bidet
what ah holy [ __ ] i got a badass
wow i'm i'm [ __ ] i have this would
did you get it free because you do the
promos
ding ding
tell him what he's won i think being
i think it shows how classy i am that i
was able to get a classy object for
next to nothing and by next to nothing i
mean literally nothing but that also
that shows me your inherent trash
because you're going i
you view that as a level up that you got
a free merchandise you both went ooh
know you bought it i thought you when i
got there i got to get my gas hole clean
and my [ __ ]
i thought you had construction done in
the bathroom and had a real bidet
no i did i did like build it build it
you know you need to put it together
come on i'll be honest with you
i didn't do that my super did i was uh
really super into playing well here's
the thing
it comes with a toilet paper no it's a
it comes with a toilet connector and you
have to replace it to a flexible hose
and my zipper is like i'll come over
because i was like i don't want to break
the toilet and then be responsible for
it so i was like all i need you to do
is take off the metal hose and i'll put
the flexible one on i'll do the rest of
it he goes okay i'll be back in an hour
he never came i had to leave for spots
and the second i left is when he showed
up so then i was just
on face time with him being like yeah so
he could just do that and he's he's a
guy from uh ecuador he's never
he's never heard of a bidet he doesn't
know what i'm doing but he set the whole
thing up and it's
it's pretty cool it's good they're nice
right hang on a second they're a life
they're such a game changer they are
you come in here you don't realize how
dirty your [ __ ] is until you really
bidet
i do i know if nothing else on these hot
days it just feels
refreshed nice it's like jumping into a
pool but just your [ __ ]
like a lemonade for your butt yeah
listen you come in here
talking about west town talking about
days yeah here's the true test
okay or whether you're on your way to a
little bit more classiness hit me
what'd you give the super for putting in
the bidet
right then i mean
but i give them a tip every christmas
with a christmas card called what's that
that doesn't count it depends on how
much work you've had
worked i've done but i mean i mean the
minimum is 50 but sometimes
sometimes it'll be a hundred and fifty
it depends if there's a lot of work
maybe i gotta go two off the bat mike no
no no
because he's also he's not he's not the
best he's not the best
he's now figured out how to get around
work because if i go hey man i need to
come over and fix this he'll go you have
to email
the landlord and then get it approved by
the landlord for him to come over so it
just buys them all this time
but you know what you know landlords or
supers are great at disappearing
one guy is like waiting on text back
from my month my super
lives in the building and he has a giant
family and when you go up to the door if
there's like an emergency
you'll knock on the door you hear a full
family eating dinner or something on the
other side of the tv on and you knock on
the door and they all just go
they just stop moving they stop moving
they stop talking until you leave and
you're like i can
hear you i can hear you going like that
i can hear you really and they just
won't answer the door
jesus yeah christ my old one used to
just get bombed up by like noon every
day
for 30 years and he was just like i
remember the guy i was living my buddy
who owned the apartment
and the one day the guy was like you're
just like wobbling around drunk at like
noon and my buddy had to go put him to
bed like on the couch
he's like dude i don't care if you drink
during the day but like this is [ __ ]
obscene nah you need that's the full new
york experience right there
the more i'm thinking about it the more
i feel like it's pretty classy to
delineate their responsibilities to the
super to set up a bidet
actually there it is i'll give you that
but a cool cheddar comes involved in
that you gotta
get a little key in the pocket i mean i
think 100
you got to give that guy something when
he you got to give him a hundred when he
does it a 100
that's more than you would never call
him a hundred dollars 50
50 right there boom there you go wow how
many how long did it take do you think
ballpark i think an hour no
yeah if that 15 minutes it's not 50
bucks
huh all right we've got some patreon
questions here folks as you know that
when you
sign up for patreon you get a question
asked on the air we have our good friend
mike feeney here with us
to field some of those questions yeah
kippy what are you thinking
we got a couple of [ __ ] barn burners
uh this one's just funny uh this is from
chris uh fist fighting your dad question
mark
do you ever uh do anything about your
dad in the family
um are the family no i mean my my dad
and i have gotten into many fights never
like
um i believe we've touched on this
before yeah there was
there's been stuff where i've been like
you know i'm running away from like
getting hit
you know kind of a thing but it's never
been a square off against them now i
will
say it's it's probably my least proud
moment of my life
you know it's one of my biggest regrets
that i'll just share with you go ahead
yeah
um there was one time my dad and i we
were on a vacation together we got in a
huge fight
how old were you uh i was when did
titanic come out
oh man it's believe me it's wildly
relevant in this situation probably 96.
it's probably like
i'm probably he was painting you nude
there was more room on that piece of
wood i tell you
this could have slid over yeah yeah
1997.
okay so i was i was probably so it was a
little bit after that so i was probably
like 12 or 13. so i was in that angst
hate everybody phase or whatever
did you have the mustache
[Laughter]
so i was all i remember is my dad and i
got into such a fight that he came like
charging at me we had two twin beds in
the hotel room and i was
like running off jumping from twin bed
to twin bed and then running around like
it was like a car
like a benny hill like he was just
chasing me and then at one point i don't
know i feel like i was cornered or
something
and then i just spit in his face
i did a rose from titanic spit in the
face
and it it uh it i mean it stopped the
fight
uh it it neutralized everything but it's
uh that's
right yeah i mean that's one of those
things where you're like you're like
once you do it you're like there's no
coming back
and i think he would have been well
within his rights to put me into a coma
at that show right after that but i
think it just took him by such a pro as
it would with anybody
it takes you by such surprise just like
it did with rose's husband
dc because you are you never expect that
that's why
yeah billy zayn billy was just like what
what
let me ask you so where were you on
vacation uh we were in california you're
in california where's the rest of the
family
uh i think it was one of those things
where like my dad had to go out for
maybe like maybe it was like a business
trip and then he was just like we'll go
a few days early and we'll go to like
you know we'll go out to california now
isn't that great
guys got a [ __ ] business trip he's
like you know what i'm gonna do i could
go myself
yeah boy take
didn't start off the clay he was chasing
his [ __ ] 12 year old son around the
ramada
it wasn't the classy as [ __ ] yeah yeah
it didn't start off the classy but i'm
just saying
but here's the weird part we had a great
rest of the trip after that after that
we had to each like
go away for like three you know an hour
maybe and then cool off and then come
back and then i'm like if you apologize
of course i did i apologize i feel like
every time i see him i feel terrible
about it jesus
yeah don't make me feel worse about it
you [ __ ]
you're like oh god i was gonna say the
guy guy works hard he brings his family
on a vacation
yeah he's chasing his kid around the
hotel room getting spit on yeah thanks
dad
yeah yeah he's got to go to [ __ ] try to
close the deal in california
he did a loogie on his feet he did have
one of the most intimidating uh
like another fight that we had uh i
forgot what it was but i was all like
i mean this is described my whole long
island upbringing i was blasting
uh my speakers that looked like this i
was blasting corn
and uh man whatever it was my dad was
either like taking a nap or we were in a
fight or whatever the hell it was and he
came
in took the corn cd out of it and he was
like you like [ __ ] corn and just went
and just exploded it in his hand like he
just one hand clinched it and it was
like
the most badass thing i had ever said i
was like yeah all right
i'm going over yeah yeah
he's since cooled down but at the time
he was uh you know he's under stress
and you can't remember what you did to
make him chase you around the hotel room
i'm sure i was just being a piece of
[ __ ] you know what i mean it's like
your kids whatever the hell you're
getting mad or arguing about it being a
brat i don't know i'm bad
i don't know i'm sure i was in the wrong
hippie might be right maybe it is him
i'm not saying that i mean yeah yeah
yeah yeah yeah this guy stinks oh yeah
yeah
come on guys let's get him he also
killed my sister yeah yeah um
all right this one uh this one's from
mike which is very telling which i also
might think it is i think it's mike my
brother uh
do you have a dumb boulder older brother
with bad eyebrows
by the way my mom about me my mom asked
me what was wrong with your eyebrows
tell that dumb bro hey daddy i might
have to cut that
your your eyebrows i think you've got
thick eyebrows she said they look darker
she's like what's going on with kippy's
eyebrows they look they're very flat
they're like underlines
hey patty this kid writes to check
something
you want to stay in that [ __ ]
necklace he got you yeah shut your mouth
patty
you want to keep ordering that above
ground pool yeah close that yap
and it's mr ryan's solar cover yeah
um solar cover
did you have an above ground pool
growing up i'm sure we've probably
talked about it yeah yeah
solar cover pool that was the only way
to warm it up oh man we have
we have a pretty trashy always a bee's
nest in that thing when you went to [ __ ]
it yeah open it up
but we would jump we would like we would
play this game called the blob my friend
you put that it was like it just looked
like blue that blue thing yeah yeah and
when it was
one of yeah it was like bubble wrap we
would go and we would jump from the
ladder of our above ground pool
into the middle of it and then try to
get out of it before drowning yeah yeah
that was the game
dude that literally that's how people
die like that many people yeah
the 90s dude yeah yeah scared are you
kidding me yeah
there was a there was a couple times
where i like things started getting dark
you know what i mean like when you're
like
i only got about 15 more than that panic
the muscle moving it's way quicker and
more you're
scratching at it yeah i can't believe
you were doing that oh it's insane
sometimes alone
it's a real cool kid i don't care for
your judgment so far
welcome to the show that's how david
carradine died
did you you're probably i'm sure you've
jumped off a trampoline into a pool at
some point
absolutely yeah yeah really that was
only safe for the first one the second
one then you're all wet yeah then your
feet
[ __ ] get back you can take a header
you hit your thigh on the siding and
then
[ __ ] i would get and my pool was my
above grandpa was surrounded by
rocks i don't know why that was like
some sort of uh
style of choice that it was just like
just white
sharp jagged rocks
jesus man i never did anything with that
so i used i still get nervous when i go
near
our pool when it's covered because i
think about lethal weapon when the guy
[ __ ] when he shot the guy and he fell
into the cover
yeah he ended up drowning that was
always instilled in this
fear stay away you're a real cool guy
but we don't have a solar cover we have
a we have a system
of pipes that like lead into other
little pipes and it heats the water and
goes into the pool
wow that sounds pricey no it's cheap now
they made it themselves actually
quite the isis if you ask me just a
couple
it's all piping jerry just a couple of
old 2-liters
a little bit of pvc we stole from the
neighborhood property of glenn on it
they were doing they were doing a
remodel next door
um all right this one's from mike who
i'm pretty sure it's my brother uh
what was the seat belt policy growing up
as a kid
did you always have to wear a seat belt
yeah i feel that's a big telltale sign
of your trash or not yeah i would wear
it but i would always be the kid who
would like i wouldn't wear this i'd like
yeah i'd put it behind me you know what
i mean and
just have the laptop yeah because when
you're a kid it's too high up in your
throat across your face
yeah why would you sit in the front seat
no the back seat yeah either side
yeah yeah they always put it behind me i
remember i don't know if you guys might
be too young around this i remember when
it was just the
just just the seat belt just the lap
yeah are too old for that
yeah that is good don't lump me in with
you
i remember when there was no roof on the
car remember when you just go
the whole rotary phone you know we
didn't have to wear one in the back seat
no no yeah yeah i was [ __ ] oh that's
why i heard i'd love to be your father
when my when i first started driving
with my friends you like backseat no
seatbelt yeah
chaos fun way to die i don't know get
thrown around there a little bit
no seatbelts in the back back of the
station wagon sitting the other way
back of the pickup truck with nothing
yeah
cleaning up yeah we were the bait we
were a big back of the pickup truck back
in the pickup truck
back in the pickup truck that was so
freedoms that's
crazy is it what is it
yeah paul is in the back seat with the
safety off
i don't know if i get that
safety off what pick a gun oh okay
okay we just smiled and didn't hit
[Laughter]
t-bone's not here right now remember the
ones that i think saturn had them you
would get in and it would be
it would be mechanical yeah i never
understood that
hyundai
[Laughter]
i'll walk i'll meet you there they tried
to do a lot of [ __ ] back then that like
seemed like you know new technology that
was [ __ ] whack
yeah get out of here imagine being
impressed by opening the door and
like but that was in the 90s that was
the height of [ __ ] technology
holy [ __ ] uh great question i didn't say
anything because it makes the edit
easier
uh this one's from drew um haven't had
one rat yet
haven't had one read yet have you or a
family member had ever had to move
because your house was haunted no
that was holy [ __ ] that's a real
question yeah would that be
because i feel like that might be
actually classy because if you have such
a big
mansion with such storied you know what
i mean that could be
perceived as classical it's not
scooby-doo
it's not a mansion yeah
the amityville horror i mean what's
happening
all those old paintings eyes following
you around
that's junkies mike i mean that's about
a scooby-doo is about as real as haunted
houses to me that's the same level
i don't know that just scared the [ __ ]
out i don't know i think i told this on
here before my sister's house was
haunted
just with like there was an old man who
died there and he would only speak to
kids
and all these kids would come over and
be like the old man upstairs told us to
be quiet
and then we're like later what the [ __ ]
they had someone come say on stuff
like that now i'm uncomfortable yeah it
was so fun
i had i refused to sleep there still to
this town she was like
stay in the guest bedroom which was the
old master bedroom
like no [ __ ] this sounds like a setup
yeah no [ __ ] getting spooned by the
old man in the middle of the night
wait this is your sister's house now yes
yeah yeah yeah
the the the the guy died there who they
bought
i wouldn't live in a house where
somebody died don't they have to tell
you that [ __ ] when you move in i don't
think so i think they found out
afterward or something
[ __ ] that they definitely don't have to
tell you if they die they have to tell
you i think if they were like
murdered there yeah really i think there
is some sort of rule
uh uh i can't do that man but i guess
you also can't prove that a ghost is
real you know what i mean
true but he only talks that he would
only talk to the kids and multiple kids
had come downstairs and been like
the old at like a party multiple
different times like throughout like a
year
the first year there they were like the
old man told us to be quiet
you're telling me they would go upstairs
and there would be no [ __ ] old man
like obviously there's no old man
upstairs
you're telling him you're telling me
he's just foley your sister still
yeah they got the police say you know if
they say the meatballs ready
he keeps running downstairs ask your mom
to lasagna's almost done
sister's house now yes you go to your
sister's house
um yes ghost in the house yeah i only
got
before it gets dark i leave buddy do you
really i mean
no but i stay downstairs
and i ain't going in the basement of the
crosstalk and he keeps his [ __ ] voice
down
not having jim yell at me wow yeah it's
pretty that's the only
i mean we stayed at that haunted house
though remember that that horn
haunted bed and breakfast yeah not scary
nothing no i mean jesus i mean we were
on the buddy system what are you talking
about
we were sleeping in ships there was four
of us in that room it was me and cotton
were in bed
and then you and sean rest in peace that
bed
somebody was on the floor me yeah me and
someone else was on the floor
they were gonna put us in multiple rooms
and we were like that's when we were
like now we'll all stay together because
we're like
back to back dude if there's ever like a
hotel where they're like hey this is a
haunted hotel come stay here
then it's like that's just tourism you
know what i mean like but if it's like
an old man being like come
come in but some guy asked him if you're
ready
what was the guy's name uh i just
deleted it chris maybe
uh send me a message on instagram i want
to hear more about your story
i want to find out what he had going on
okay i don't like this they can't be
going rogue
yeah what the [ __ ] hey email me after
the show will you welcome back to ghost
garbage
yeah this is gonna be some sort of
[ __ ] spin-off you're trying to cook
up
um no i just want to hear if he had to
move because of it
that stuff scares me man i don't like
that [ __ ] yeah you want to come over my
sister's house this weekend
no um when i was in when i was in
theater school
walking the boards as we said listen you
[ __ ] studied acting at a ymca in like
ridley pennsylvania
okay what are we talking about i'm done
i'm done playing along with this
shakespeare gentleman shakespeare
it was a community center it was in a
really old neighborhood
really old area in pa and a bunch of
rich people lived in the area and their
kids would like come and take classes at
the school and [ __ ] like that
and we became friends with a couple of
families and me and my boy were over
having dinner one night at one of the
one of the kids parents houses and they
were talking about how the house was
haunted and they
they've seen this and they've seen that
and we're like hey get the leg out of
here
and as soon as somebody said something
the chandelier just [ __ ]
came off and just smashed in the middle
of the of the kitchen table
wow yeah i was out yeah i wouldn't [ __ ]
later
i don't even like being in my parents
house by myself if i'm down the basement
and i gotta go i turn the lights off and
sprint up the stairs he be
a gb yeah i don't [ __ ] with that you
don't get scared of that stuff
no i mean what what freaked me out as a
kid was that i watched that movie
leprechaun too young that horror movie
and i always i never [ __ ]
i still won't watch it and that thing i
still can't eat lucky jokes yeah
i hated that because he was like short
enough to be like under your bed you
know and
grab your foot or something like that
that was that [ __ ] dude
i had to [ __ ] do like a pole vault
out of my bed in the morning
[ __ ] that oh man poltergeist too [ __ ]
me up that clown [ __ ] wrapping his
hands around that kid
yeah anything getting drug under the
beds
that is no good what was it pet cemetery
where he's is he waiting under the bed
and pet cemeteries yeah slices the
achilles tendon oh
no way that little devil thing nope not
doing it
would you rather would you rather look
up and see like somebody looking in the
window at you
or something grab you from under the bed
if i'm in my head enough i'll still get
scared that something's under the bed
i'm not lying yeah i'll lay there just
like dude you're nuts it's fine it's
totally okay
there's nothing under there but i'm for
sure thinking something's under there
yeah there's i constantly have that
thing where you like hear a noise in
your apartment you like
open one eye and you're like you have to
do the thing we go
even if i decide that something's going
to be there what am i going to do what
am i going to do about it like that
happened to my wife
i wasn't home and i had my like a shirt
hanging up on top of like an
open closet door and she woke up
and thought there was a murderer there
but was like
resolved to die and she's like what am i
gonna do and then just rolled back to
bed
waiting for impending death yeah good
for her yeah i'm gonna die i'm gonna be
comfy as well
yeah yeah she's like hey i'm going to
bed do what you got to do bro
but my eyes look good at the funeral
yeah yeah i don't know if i ever
i i might have thought on like a hard
feelings or something we were in
switzerland and we stayed at this like
farmhouse and the person was supposed to
be there it was airbnb they were
supposed to be there to check us in but
they were like hey
i had to leave the places we're in the
middle of the mountains if we get there
can't figure out the lights it's like an
old wooden [ __ ] log cabin
sketchy to begin with and i'm looking
around for like a light switch and i
look under the [ __ ] stairs and
there's just a clown mask
hanging off on a nail under this and i
see it and now i'm freaked off i'm like
this is it
and it's next to a sickle and like a
like
one of those old souls with like yeah
your whole like
they're they're mountain people come on
down to jigsaw
yeah stay for the weekend dude so i'm
freaking the [ __ ] and i can't tell my
wife because i'm like this would like
show [ __ ] panic so now i'm nervous
and she's like what's wrong with you i'm
not
i'm like listen [ __ ] we're [ __ ]
we're about to get [ __ ] clipped here
this ain't good and i showed her in the
morning she's like yeah thanks thank
thank you for not telling me that oh my
god
no one should own a sickle i think yeah
what's that all about where are you
staying
i i mean i wouldn't have stayed there
kinky sex hotels
listen there was no kinky sex that night
i'll tell you that much
oh god family a family friend of ours
when they were when they were young
they're like my parents age
they were uh they had a house in like
conshohocken or something like that
to catch a hacker a jackknife tractor
trailer on the catcher hacking
i don't know why i said it no one knows
forgot to argue
except for the locals out there what's
up uh shout out to friend zones
um great pizza sweet sauce you like
sweet sauce mikey
like when it's a little sweet yeah sure
man
you went like seven references deep now
where i'm like in the sunken place of
this story so
you gotta pull me out with wherever it
was i got you so
you're back you're in conshohocken yeah
the cops are there mentally the couple
the couple's in the couple's in bed and
they're sleeping
okay and um the uh his mom
they didn't have kids yet but his mom
was like you know like kind of like
tossing and turning she like
felt like she heard something or
something like that and she
woke up but she didn't really move she
just kind of like you know opened her
eyes and woke up
and she just heard this really soft
voice go maybe we should tie them up
there's two dudes in the house robbing
the place what
yeah she's like maybe we should tie them
up and she just closed her eyes and just
[ __ ] went back to sleep and
and they continued robbing and then
continued robbing and and then left
and then she woke up then chopping she
she rolled over and walked her husband
up how long
how how much did they i this is this is
the whole show now
how many wait a minute how many things
did they take
a lot was it like they were they out of
there in 30 seconds i mean was i think
it probably took a few minutes
wow see mike where you're going wrong
here is you're asking foley for
follow-ups to the head yeah yeah yeah
yeah
you got you got the good line that's it
keep it moving yeah all right
[ __ ] me i guess i'll be honest i'm not
even sure that happened
if we're descending into foleyville that
might that might not even be a thing i
might have seen it on netflix
but i was drunk nah that really happened
whoa but the scary point was is that
that maybe we should tie them up yeah i
mean i right they're trying to
try to pretend like you're asleep that
well i regularly have that nightmare of
like getting
shot once in like some sort of mass
shooting situation and i'm like clipped
but i'm not
like uh mortally wounded but i pretend
that i'm like actually dead
trying to decaffein and then they walk
up and then finish the job i'm not gonna
lie jesus christ
i yeah yeah i've had that not i mean but
the thing where like i am hurt or
something i realize i'm not gonna get
away and i go oh i'll play dead
yeah i'll hide over here yes please i
mean like low self-esteem or something
that's not good
well maybe it's also because i'm like if
i ever was killing somebody i would
never
just shoot you never just shoot them
once if i ever killed anybody
it's gonna be if i shoot someone i'm
shooting them like nine times
i'm finishing the clip you know i've got
to empty it one in every vital organ
area [ __ ] that
no chance jesus christ i
i don't know i really smooth cool cat
just saying
this mustache i'm just saying don't
cross me
more of the story above ground pool
though huh yeah
oh god um all right this one's from bilo
is it garbage to waddle your way out of
the bathroom mid [ __ ] to
do something get something it's
obviously not toilet paper if you're
jammed up you have to do that you got to
do what you got to do
yeah yeah yes man if you're like
waddling out to get because you forgot
your phone or something
ah that's it answer the door because
everything smooshes
yeah no yeah you never want to do that i
have had a thing where delivery was
buzzing
and they're only going to stay for so
long and i have done like uh like
a quick a quick waddle smash the butt
like the
and then run back and finish and then
get to the door in time it was some of
my finest work
that's pretty good you got to be giant
you're a [ __ ] cooking you can't make
them
you can't make a bad move in that
situation yeah yeah you got everything
has to go
perfect you gotta execute perfect that's
gonna be like born supremacy
we synchronized a watch he hits nine to
let him in
yeah i got i got 19 seconds to go yeah
that's a quick why what are you [ __ ]
aaron rodgers
i think i had already started the white
process okay so it was just more
start the white process give yourself a
wipe or two yeah let him get two buzzes
before he calls you know so you don't
have to run after the first buzz yeah to
that second buzz
right and when he starts dialing then
you're like you know you buzz him in
yeah but um what's your buzzer
what's your buzzer stitch you just got
like it's like the standard i have a
phone they put a new i haven't oh
that's very nice mine just goes like
that this is one of those things
i've never once asked who is it really
you just buzz up
if you buzz if you buzz my apartment
you're getting in the building
amazon packages there's like uh one two
three there's like three floors of
people and uh
you know probably eight or eight to ten
apartments that's big enough yeah i mean
that's not your fault
yes well like it's also too like fedex
where they just start hitting the
buttons yeah get in the [ __ ] door
yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah
i don't hate it i'm with that i mean if
you're if there's only like four
apartments that are sure it's a little
dicey but you shouldn't let anybody in
the building so packages are getting
stolen no they get stolen when you leave
the packages out out front the door when
anyone can get in you need to get them
into the building where they're safe
yeah wow we've we've been having them
getting jacked from inside the building
then you know it's coming from inside
the building
so you know it's somebody in the
building so that's a local or somebody's
business or somebody that you buzzed in
yeah bozo oh not my building
not my package not my problem hey tough
breaking about your scotch tape
i also don't care about things getting
stolen really they all i mean
there's cameras everywhere i feel like
they replace it
yeah amazon's like if you go hey i never
got my package oh okay there's
it's on its way already you ever get a
thing this is how much money amazon's
making you ever get a thing and you're
like oh this isn't
how i wanted it to be or i don't like
this i'm going to return it and they're
like
just keep it we don't want it back don't
even send it back we'll send you
something else we'll refund you but
just keep it and you're like oh how many
things can i do this with
you know like we don't want to have to
pay somebody to field this thing and
open
it up and put it back it's not worth it
it's not worth it i've done that with
like it cost us nine cents and we're
gonna have to pay a guy
you know 12 an hour to open this and
file it and do paperwork i've done that
with dog treats a bunch
like you get different dog traits from
my dog and then i was like you try one
he's like guy he's not a fan they're
like just
just keep it and you're like well now
he's a fan because he eats anything
he always loves them that's what you got
to do you got to grift you got to game
the system
you are a little bit of a grifter well i
come from a family a bit yeah my mom is
a grifter
and really she's like she's like she's
like aladdin you know what i mean where
she's good at like the
all right uh she got a good voice yeah
yeah one step
no she's uh yeah yeah she could do the
apple off her arms
no what you would do is we would go to
concerts a lot as a well there's two
scams she would always run we go to
concerts a lot
and you just like you're talking scams i
don't you tell me i think it's like
low-level grifting it's more like
manipulation like social
manipulation that she's very good at
sounds like a sweet lady she's she's one
of the best
um but she looked like i was gonna get a
little sorry missus
[ __ ] she's one of the best second story
men
yeah so we go to a uh you know we go to
concerts she would always buy like
nosebleed seats you know we go to like
jones beach or whatever nassau costume
who are you seeing
uh you know your mom arrow smith she was
huge out into arrowsmith
um first concert was hooting the
blowfish stuff like that a lot of rock
right so
whatever so one time we were going to
see aerosmith and we had these nosebleed
seats and this is my mom every single
time 10 minutes after the concert
started she's like
come on and we just start going down and
this is her move which is so [ __ ]
brilliant and there's no way it doesn't
work
still anyone can do this she goes up to
a security guard and she goes
who's the uh who is the the old head of
security here
and he goes you mean rosie she's like
rosie that's right yeah
i remember all right have a good night
and then she leaves then she goes
late we walk over a little further to a
different part to a different security
guard and she goes
hey rosie's working here tonight and she
go and they go no no rosie just retired
to be here 25 years and they're like oh
my god that sucks every time bro i've
known her forever we went to high school
together with rosie and she would always
let us sneak down like you know rosie
you're kooba rosie all right go ahead go
in there
and we would literally go like front row
sometimes backstage it's just like you
get little pieces of information
from each person and then you just build
it up to a bigger and bigger thing
hectic man god damn it yeah it is
it is like a [ __ ] it's just full
confidence and then she'd be like we
have pictures with arrowsmith backstage
and rosie yeah yeah thanks rosie i have
a feeling
that your subconscious has made up rosie
there was no rosie and your mom was just
flashing her tits together
that's what i said she's like a groupie
without the [ __ ] man i don't know
when we go to but also here's like a low
level one which people can still do
uh we will go to mcdonald's and she
would make up fake coupons
in the drive-thru she would order just
say i gotta buy one get one
your face got so serious when you really
you were like
i didn't know you could do that yeah oh
yeah she would just make them up she
would like i gotta buy one get one free
big mac meal and they'd be like okay and
like 99
of the time they don't ask until the one
time that they did
she would just pretend like she lost the
coupon in the drive
blown out the win in the drive around
she had the big coupon book so she'd be
like
filing through she's like it was just
here i'm so sorry and then they'll just
go just go
but because she understand time is money
in mcdonald's the longer you stall
people are beeping people are getting
pissed off they're like just go we don't
care we know there's no such thing as a
buy none
get three free anything
that was like the way yeah i did all
that [ __ ] man i would do that with
blockbuster i would rent a game
if my video game broke i would go rent
that same game swap them out and then go
back make a scene then they give you a
coupon to rent a free game next time so
the next time your thing breaks
that's how i put blockbuster out of
business wait so you have a video
game you have uh i have a video game
that i own
yeah nhl hockey so yeah and they go it's
wayne gretzky's 3d hockey for nintendo
64.
that was best hockey game
let's get it and play right now i so
let's say that game breaks i go to
blockbuster i rent wayne gretzky's 3d
hockey
i go swip swap i swap them out i give it
it's a classic swip swap maneuver right
there
what michael's doing right here guys
who might recognize it as the old swip
swipe yeah the old blockbuster shuffle
and that's not the blockbuster shuffle
so we'd i just go back and you got to
make a scene you can't just
return it because then you could get
charged for the game yeah like this game
was [ __ ] you'd be like i spent my
allowance money what's going on
why are you holding it in the air 24
going i spent my whole
time i took out the trash can for three
weeks
so here's six [ __ ] lawns i gotta cut
for this piece of [ __ ] but this is where
the rub is this is how it actually this
is how you set yourself up for a
lifetime of free rentals at
a business that went out of business 25
years ago uh is that you
when you go in when you say it broke
they will always go well just go rent
another copy of it and it's fine
but you can't do that because you go you
know what this whole experience has
soured my entire thing i don't even want
the game anymore
and then they'll go this is a 13 year i
would've told you to get the [ __ ] out of
them
because you broke the game and they
blockbuster can't handle that so they
give you a coupon
to come rent next time you want to rent
a video game and then that's
a lot of work no it's not it's a five
dollar commitment for a lifetime of free
games because i paid five it's not the
free games you're st
you're replacing your game that broke
yes blockbuster is
yes yeah but for five dollars once and
then every game after that i have a
coupon for a free
rental so i'll just go in next time my
next game breaks
when the wayne gretzky 3d hockey what
are you doing to these games
i'm winning and my friends are getting
mad and breaking the game out of anger
toby broke the game holy i would never
break that game because i would never
lose
damn i would never think to do that
that's garbage right there i like it
is it garbage i feel like it's like yes
it's good
yeah yeah there's a difference between
rich and poor but also
in like shrewd is shrewd garbage do you
consider being shrewd
i don't really know what's true video
games but stealing video games that's
garbage
yeah i don't know how you want to spit
you don't know what shrewd is you don't
know what an adirondack chair is i don't
know
i don't know what the adirondack
mountains are
let's let's just go to it totally cut
that out
can we edit him out of this whole
episode please oh
god damn yeah that's i mean anytime
you're doing scams to get
like that's not even like a one step the
coupon thing i get i lost the coupon
yeah but yours is like a seven year con
mine yeah i did it until they went out
of business
and i'm just surprised that that you had
the the the confidence
as a teenager to act like you know
uh like you know like an adult in there
this is this was a terrible but the
people that work
there are also teenagers yeah that's
what i'm saying my mom taught me
everything i mean i'm backstage i have
to drop my kids off at school and deal
with this
yeah yeah my husband will be doing the
whole thing
yeah now i'm not gonna have dinner ready
or my husband gets home because of this
game if you're if you're paying full
price for anything you're a sucker
that's what i always say what are their
little scams
retail is for i'll i'm happy to pay
retail
yeah i'm not i'm not doing anything talk
to you no i don't want you to look
no i'm not saying you got a barter but i
mean even like banana republic if
if you're if you have an email address
banana republic does 40
off everything like eight times a month
so if you're the one
schmuck that's walking in there the
first monday and you're like
77 for a button up that sounds
reasonable and it's 42
a day later what are you doing yeah yeah
that's garbage i won't even sign it
that's garbage i won't sign up for that
i'm taking this
yeah yeah yeah even if like you i go to
a website like i just bought a pair of
adidas and it was like i like a coupon
i like it i don't like it's too much
clicking i don't do it i just go
whatever you got me also the two things
that you have flexed as you
leveling up your bidet and your shirt
were both
bought at a discount jumping through
hoops or free well the
the couch was full price that i had to
pay for but again west hell what are you
going to do did you try
yeah well of course i tried
to slip and fall i did i sent him a
picture of him under the couch
i did get kind of a discount actually
because when i went to west elm i bought
the couch and they were like we also got
another like a single seat
and i was like if we get both of them
can you throw in can you throw in a deal
for that and they'll go we'll knock like
150 bucks off that so i did get
something on that
i had to spend an incredible amount of
money to get to save 200 bucks
still a win 200 bucks that's a lot of
mcdonald's
you know that's a win to a dirtbag yeah
i love it mikey [ __ ] one step ahead
of the law gotta think
man kids doing this guy sticks and moves
jesus christ um this one this guy's name
is a [ __ ] home run
uncle hank's weapons gray titanium
tongue compressor
fully stung when he laughs gets insane
uh this is ever try to recreate a fast
food joint signature menu item at home
that's awesome oh that's a great
question
who hasn't tried to make a big mac i
haven't tried it yeah
yeah me neither oh that third button
such an unnecessary component if you're
gonna make it at home you're gonna make
it with only two buns right you know
what's one of the greatest lies
in in the world the devil no the fact
that there's not
another slice of cheese on the second
burger on a big mac
is that a lie no yeah it's not there no
i mean
they don't have it sure that's not like
a mandela effect thing where that was
something
i just told them what that is don't get
them it's a whole you
you think the adirondack care
explanation was tough
no cornucopia no it's um wait what about
fruit
oh no come on tell me i want to know
killing me dude what's fruit in the loom
the underwear there you know the what's
the fruit of the loom symbol
what's the logo of fruit of the loom uh
grapes
apples yep um orange and somebody else
and that little cornucopia thing right
that little like basket basket no
there's no basket
all right well there you go oh is that
what you said no i don't know most
people think there's a basket i don't
see the big there is
i see the bat there isn't there has
never been a basketball oh yeah really
like
can you look up a big mac there's no
cheese on the top on the top burger
it's [ __ ] [ __ ] yes the middle bun
is completely unnecessary
and also it's the same thing with the
turkey club you're like you're just it's
just you don't need that
i wonder why wait that's not a basket
yeah that does that's not real really
yeah that's a that's a rip-off yeah it's
just that one right there yeah
just that one can you believe it yeah
now you're into it
adirondack chairs let's go
see wow that's pretty good that might
not even be an adirondack chair
i wouldn't say i think you would love
one but it would be
quite a struggle is it one of those is
it one of those ones that have it looks
like a v
almost no it's like this it's i'll just
pull one up whatever oh i know what
you're talking
about of course it's that it's every
wood chair
yeah yeah yeah that's like plastic i
thought you meant the one with the cloth
that goes like that
i don't know i don't know what you're
talking about what that means that's an
end that's that's a fully effect yeah
we've we're now in the depths of
foleyville and it's
tough to get out i feel like i'm
drowning in my solar cover right now
yeah i'm just doing this scratching at
the table
oh holy crap i grabbed your leg at the
bottom of the pool yeah
where are you going mikey yeah should we
tie him up
uh i got a question for the trio boys
i'm listening
from across the pond our boy over there
in the uk uh
emmanuel okay um it's a hypothetical in
the style of
mike feeney and friend of the show mike
cannon and brandon sagli's podcast here
today
i'm not friends with them but yeah sorry
just go on there's a scenario available
everywhere check us out on patreon too
there you go if you were a nail a nail
technician and you came across someone
who had six fingers
would you charge extra for the sixth
finger absolutely i would
i don't think that they charge by the
finger well no but it's based on
ten fingers yeah the price is better i
wouldn't be much more
five percent more hmm
especially like a manicure too is a lot
of work you know it's like a lot of
filing cutting they're painting they're
doing a lot of stuff to it have you ever
had a manicure or a pedicure
i've had a manicure and a pedic i grew
up in my mom worked in salons growing up
so i grew up with she was a nail
technician so like that was what i grew
up around that i'm all about the pettys
but i've had
i've i've recently got back into the
world of petty sometimes when my wife
goes i'll go get a pedi while she gets a
mani pedi and it is
delightful it is one of those things
where you're like
i get why women are trying to keep this
a secret
it's just like a fun you're in the
massage chair and there's that weird
stigma if a guy's in there that it's
like
an effeminate thing or there's like some
question to your
manhood or something like that and i'll
see like old
like leather-skinned italian guy like
for sure connected guys sitting in there
getting you know getting their hands
done you know and you're like it's a
it's it's quite an experience fantastic
i get i get pedicures done
just for the all the get all the dead
skin off the bottom of my face yeah with
the oh they get the razor to it they
shave it that cheese looking thing
yeah oh man that thing they always feel
like
with your pecorino
back there making a caesar you know and
then they put the ketchup on my
girlfriend's fingernails
yummy it's just a waiter say when
darling please use thousand island today
i did that thing i was i was
uh in the czech republic and you put
your feet in and the fish eat the dead
oh yeah the dead skin ticklish i would
get so ticklish i would like
involuntarily like stomp out the fish
you don't really feel it's like very
does it work yeah i guess i don't know
not like the [ __ ] razor well when the
woman holds if she holds my foot and
she's trying to do something there it'll
i'll like do one of these like and they
always look at you like
ticklish loser and i'm like listen
you're you're tickling the arch of my
foot you're lucky you don't get a heel
to your nose yeah i just started getting
comfortable with people touching my feet
just this [ __ ] you know how to play cool
man listen
don't look me in the eye yeah i don't
think people touching my feet
immediately in a mexican standover
oh god that's pretty [ __ ] good
um this is a pretty good one this is
from snake with arms
uh don't fully understand that a
terrifying visual
when a cashier asks if you would like to
donate to a cause when checking out do
you donate and how much
i don't even i go so far as to purposely
go in my head like when they're talking
about whatever it is because i don't
ever believe it's going to them
yeah the very small percentage actually
gets there and is useful i don't i never
done no no
never never ever the only one i donate
to is saint jude's
shout out to st jude of course yeah what
are you good at yeah but i mean would
you like to donate thomas
they've been really pushing like hey
would you they
they've been hitting you with like local
families would you like to donate a
dollar to local families in need
it makes me think the guy's like out
front and i gotta walk by him yeah you
know what i mean like
give me a dollar yeah sorry buddy yeah
you'll see 32 cents of that in six to
eight weeks
yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah it's all a
scam everybody's trying to remember
remember the
unicef the little the little boxes with
the pennies halloween
i learned about that later but yeah you
didn't get that at halloween
we never did it now oh we got them at
how our teachers gave them to us the
night before halloween
yeah we were going on trick-or-treating
yeah we had to [ __ ] do a little
shakedown too
yeah all right yeah yeah we got snickers
and some pennies skim some pennies off
the top
i think yeah one i think maybe once or
twice we just never turned it in and
just kept it
that sweet 17 cent profit that was my
mom's idea
oh your mom was like that too huh and it
comes all the way around
pull the old mrs phoenix yeah quick
mikey put this neck brace on
um holy [ __ ]
all right this one is from xander's the
garbage have a kitchen-sized garbage can
in your bedroom
yeah it's a tough life oh that's garbage
yeah that's too much eating or drinking
whatever you're doing i don't even think
i have a trash i don't have a trash can
in my garb
in my bedroom yeah i did it away or
maybe we have a small waste basket in
the corner
you really switched on that now either
way maybe a small yeah maybe a small
mid size yeah maybe a tall kitchen
kitchen receptacle a dumpster
a cardboard baler
that was did you have a trash compactor
growing up no and we also didn't have
the one in the drain we didn't have
either the garbage disposal
we didn't have either of those that's
how that's how some things you can't
grip buddy
can't grip class kid you can have all
the blockbuster video games you want
yeah
you can't talk your way into a sunlight
oh did you have a garbage disposal
uh garbage disposable maybe in one of
those
disposable garbage disposal yeah
garbage is disposable no garbage
disposal garbage disposal
no that's not right garbage disposal
garbage disposal oh yeah that is right
okay
holy vine this is what happens when
foley has a couple of pops
was that he's got [ __ ] ipa you said
the same word
six times until it sounded right to you
your garbage disposal wave of the future
wave of the future wave of the future
the end of the aviator yeah jesus christ
i got a little dampering disposal um
we had a garbage disposal at uh
disposable
disposable carpet yeah but we never had
that that trash compactor was [ __ ]
rich people [ __ ] yeah i had special i
remember uh
right they they weren't good or were
they good i mean i never would it make
it like a little brick
yeah would just [ __ ] keep crushing it
down my aunt has one now
real good huh somebody had asked uh
either
they sent me a message or i saw it on
twitter or instagram
um we might have talked about it before
but
the trash can underneath the cabinet
that's clear if you can't understand
i think if you can't see the trash can
that's classy
i know but that's a much smaller trash
can underneath but it doesn't matter
but it's not out it's not visible that's
the you know
the fact that you can't see it is the
classy aspect i think the thing that
makes a garbage can
uh classy is if you don't have to touch
it to open it if you could either do a
wave or step or the step
as long as you're not physically
touching the thing yeah you know what's
totally trash but real fun wall-mounted
can crusher
oh that's we've done that early on in
the show that's [ __ ] next-level
garbage
yeah yeah that or a bottle opener on the
wall
yeah yeah that's tough yeah never had
that not in the kitchen you could have
we have one in the deck on the back deck
my cousin made one but it's just a two
by four with a bottle opener
it's drilled into it just like the you
know that
regular like two by four stain there's
like no
it just was from home depot into the
earth still raw wood
yeah that's awesome holy [ __ ]
good stuff um this one's nuts anthony
uh this have you ever saran wrap
someone's car
oh of course you have yeah prank
prank in high school we saran wrap
someone's car when they were getting out
of it
they were in a date at the movies and we
found their car
saran wrapped it up and then i think we
like i think we also put like
food on it like tomatoes and [ __ ] like
that
yeah yeah i saw it once really ruined
that date yeah yeah really cockblocked
that kid
[ __ ] [ __ ] yeah i don't even
remember why i don't even know what
friend of yours or good friend that one
of my best man
literally oh yeah yeah yeah yeah we were
just
i don't know i just thought that that we
just all thought that would be a real
fun
piece of [ __ ] thing to do we would have
food fights while driving
each other's car like we would drive
multiple cars and we would
throw food at each other from car to car
yeah yeah that seems dangerous
of course surely yeah we never did
anything cranky like that we would sneak
out in the middle of the night and throw
golf balls at cars when they were
driving by
you know light-hearted man golf balls
vehicular manslaughter you're like the
kid that was it was a big thing in long
island
he would he threw they tried to do a
prank like that and they threw a turkey
over and over like a you know oh no i
would never do something frozen turkey
over there
killed somebody yeah yeah yeah no i had
everything i had a group of friends
they all got caught it was like 10 guy
they all like met we were in like junior
high
we didn't go it was me and a couple
other kids didn't go for some reason
they all met up in the middle of the
night
like smoke weed or drink or whatever
nice and then they started like
throwing it started off with like a
hacky sack they dropped off like an
overpass under the car
and then it was like a soccer ball and
the soccer ball hit and flew like you
know ten thousand feet
oh that must have been so funny and then
the next was like a rock murder
and it would just smash this guy's
windshield and then like dude they think
they call because there's nothing going
on in like our tiny sleepy town it's
like the swat team came
oh my god just [ __ ] ran up on these
kids with like automatic weapons drawn
and [ __ ] we used to stay in
like [ __ ] themselves there was like this
woods area that had like you know
dirt jumps that we all made out to a
dirt jump yeah
once we made a nice set of doubles what
up yeah for some reason it was like
cooler yeah yeah tabletop for sure
yeah so we had that and there was like a
main road right off that i'm gonna get
my schwinn predator right yeah
i had my harrow baby and uh honey where
did they go with the pegs
somebody had to have some kind of
construction equipment to build those no
no that was just
my buddies or just friends and a shovel
yeah shovels did you start from scratch
okay there was always one oh yeah there
was like the kids
the kids that were older than a star you
know you just kind of add sure yeah yeah
yeah
but but it was the uh we would also go
in there and we would like throw eggs at
cars because it was like right next to a
main road
and there would be a stop sign that
would go like a two-way stop sign
and we were there in the fall so all the
leaves were on the ground they
were kind of filling up the the jumps
and we were throwing eggs and all my
buddies
lit up this one car as he stopped i mean
five of us maybe hit it with eggs and
the guy got out of his car and he was
like i'm gonna [ __ ] he was you know
he's probably like in his mid-20s
jack's long island he goes i'm gonna
[ __ ] kill you and starts
running towards us leaves his car door
uh a car running car door open
and run storages in the woods and i
immediately go from like ha oh
and i turn and my buddies are already
running away there are so far so i'm the
last one and i hear dude it was the
scariest moment of my
life i still could hear the swishing
through the leaves getting louder and
closer to me and i was like i'm gonna
get killed
my way down to play dead uh well very
close i
dove into one of the dirt jumps that
were covered in leaves and i swear to
god i must have stayed in there for
45 minutes i think that they the guy
left probably after two minutes but
i stayed in there hey man i can get your
free games of blockbuster dude i stayed
there so long that my buddies had come
back and they were like my come on like
he's gone and i still was like no no no
he's just holding a knife to their
throat being like call the other guy
get him follow him call him and i'm like
don't do it it's a setup it's a setup
they're dead to you mike just move on
without him
i had a body do that we were throwing
drunk in high school throwing snowballs
at a car like we were just sitting in
front of my buddy's house winging snow
it was one of my favorite things i still
do that
and what snowballs at cars yeah i have a
little balcony i throw snowballs at cars
every time it snows it's so much fun and
then you
hide no i just go in my house what are
they going to do get out of their car
they can't get into the building unless
they buzz and then i'm like
that's 3b that's 3b hang on i'm taking
this [ __ ] yeah yeah
no the same thing i'm like joking and
the guy stops it was a good you know it
was a guy in his 20s or whatever like
late 20s he was like
just [ __ ] this he pulls in and like we
all like run like whatever and then my
buddy double backs and steals the guy's
car because he left the door
what an escalation just jogging away
like oh this guy's never going to catch
us and then my body's like
oh my tokyo drifts around the corner
guys get in fun prank this is bad but
then the guy ended up coming back to the
house
he whatever and he was just like yo i'm
not mad
that was [ __ ] insane and he like came
in and drank with us and [ __ ]
what yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah i feel
like he'd be
like you don't let him in your house
because that's one of the guys where he
just goes yeah no that was fun man that
was real fun let me get inside and just
like look around and hang out with you
get you drunk and sleepy yeah yeah no i
think he's like playing pranks
yeah he was i like praying prankster
very fun
very congratulations your mother's dad i
think he thought because he was like oh
i'm gonna [ __ ] with these kids
like so he was like i'm going to
escalate it and then he got escalated
yeah he got got he was like oh whatever
i'm fighting he got escalated yeah
it wasn't escalated
what the [ __ ] sounds like a bad mtv
prank show welcome back to escalated
yeah
all right that one in there i'll work on
that pitch for next week i'm going to
make final cut
it's going to be on teddy's floor uh
let's do one more then we got to get the
[ __ ] out of here
ten bucks i'll make that disappear yeah
i would love if toby started charging
that's the kind of bad joke
yeah otherwise it stays in the allure of
this whole show goes away people are
like wait that's that's what they're
like unedited
you record for eight hours get an hour
out of it yeah it's dark outside now we
started
we never edited anything on the podcast
especially me
yeah toby cuts his own bombs out but
then lets me and fully [ __ ]
die if you think that's saying you're
you've got another thing
no we uh we we don't do any edits um
well i i didn't i wasn't serious until
you just said that
that was the only thing i think pull a
bank job but you you just blew it you
just game everything hey guys hold for
the edit
um this all right this is a good one
that we can get out of this
this is from the facebook group this is
uh from chris scotch out of that
facebook group
uh ever take pictures with you and your
significant other in matching outfits
i feel like that might be a you thing
i've
never wore a matching outfit with
anybody
even like as a halloween thing not even
a mario luigi
what are you saying no for i guarantee
there's a picture of you in a yankees
jersey and your dog in a yankees jersey
there i mean listen that's a different
story that's it for us guys
it's not bad tuning next week no no
they're not matching i was wearing a
jerk it was opening day
i was wearing a jersey it was a dollar
dog
he had a manager jacket on you know he
had the it was different colors one was
royal blue one was the pinstripes
does he have a manager jacket yeah it
was he's a cool little manager jacket
like
like nylon ones it's awesome dude it's
awesome it looks like his name is jeter
it's like come on he's [ __ ]
he's a yankee he sits there on the bench
making decisions
i've heard enough i've heard enough goes
out to the mound talks to the pitcher
yeah he's kicking dirt out yeah he goes
what do you think how much more you got
you got some left in you gonna get this
next guy they get more treats from
amazon
i like it gang that is the show mikey
you got anything you want them to know
out there what do you got coming up
i'd like to know first off if if you
guys think i've i've regressed or have
gotten less garbage i think it's insane
that you think you've you think west elm
tushy you got one thing
tushy the tushy was free promotional
products
one thing should be something you know
throw into your throwing snowballs at
cars
that's yeah like dennis diminished
you're buzzing anybody into the building
um all right you're looking for scams
left and right
not to be trusted it's a whole world of
people out there just waiting to be
taken advantage of jesus christ um how
was the mustache talking yeah
yeah sorry sorry buttercup is that
offended um
don't tread on me i uh you guys can
listen to uh my podcast here's the
scenario with mike cannon brendan
sagalow we also have a patreon
uh please go watch my comedy special
rage against the routine available
on my youtube channel and please thank
you boys and please follow me on social
media at i am mike feeney
oh and if you play video if you like
watching people play video games
twitch.tv slash ny fresh makeup like
watching people play stolen video
games elaine gretzky kippy what do you
got for me uh as always
uh make sure you subscribe on itunes
that actually doesn't even really matter
anymore uh youtube those numbers are
true to roof and patreon.com and i'm at
kevin ryan comedy on all social media
also toby's making me say
uh follow at are you garbage on twitter
and instagram
we just passed ten thousand on twitter
are about to pass it on instagram we
need that swipe up
need that swipe up baby gang we love you
we will see you next week
peace